sometimes i think back to pre-baby and i
would look at other people who have one
kid two kids and i just assumed everyone
knew what they were doing
and most people i think are kind of just
winging it yeah they read a couple books
maybe
and they just feel like
i'm just gonna i'm just gonna do what i
think is best but that's why having a
community as best as you can is so
helpful because it helps you get
insights and wisdom from different
people
on things that you're like oh i never
even considered that work on yourself to
not take things personally because what
people are doing
is really more about them and not about
you yeah i think it's obviously easier
said than done it takes a lot of inner
work
and
detaching
and some people just are naturally and
this is sort of discussing the other day
like why are some people just naturally
so good at
not taking things personally almost to a
fault where you're like they don't
andrew my husband that is the epitome of
someone who does not care what people
think of him anytime you find yourself
being quick to judge
like check in with yourself and be like
why am i why do i have these strong
opinions about this other person like
why can i what can i do to work on
myself for many many people
if you can start to feel extreme
gratitude for where you are now
and what you know is coming because if
you can desire it it means that you're
desiring it for a reason there's nothing
wrong with desiring more for your life
and i that was pivotal for me because i
thought i felt guilty for wanting more
[Music]
that was hannah mcneely my sister if you
don't know we are 14 months apart and we
are inseparable she is my best friend
and we tell each other everything she's
a huge source of inspiration in my life
and i'm so thankful for how we've been
able to help each other grow throughout
the years and in this conversation
you'll get a little sneak peek into how
we
converse and discuss things we talk
about all different kinds of things from
juggling motherhood to her
entrepreneurial mindset shifts that
she's had over the last years in her
life and just living a fulfilling life
to what it was like for us growing up in
our childhoods and our parents
transitioning to plant-based how to make
a plant-based diet sustainable including
talking a little bit about her
course that she recently came out with
called vegan for good it's incredible
definitely check it out if you're
interested linked below
and we dabble all different kinds of
things including internal
mindset shifts that you can have in your
own growing journey
like things like not taking things
personally from other people and
learning to
try to see people from their differing
perspectives and understanding why
people think the way that they do
trying to judge less and just focus more
on your own inner growth i loved having
her on the podcast because of course
we're best friends and we have so much
fun talking together so i hope you enjoy
our conversation let's get into it get
ready for a really big conversation this
is another test yeah
all right hannah welcome to the podcast
thank you for having me i'm so happy to
be here because
it's the ellen fisher podcast i met
someone on the plane who was like
i know that podcast you did i told you i
forget it remember because they um said
they're working with underground
railroad i said my sister's gonna have
the
founder on and then
she said which podcast i said the ellen
fisher podcast and instead of saying i
watch her youtube channel she said
i love that podcast alright i know that
podcast and it's like it's cool to be
known by the podcast yes actually when i
was like walking across the street one
day a few months ago
a car pulled up
outside
and it was a guy who was driving
normally it's like i have a largely
female audience but it was a guy who's
driving he rolled down the window was
like hey are you that podcast lady i was
like
yes yes i am yes i am that podcast
that is the affirmation i tell myself
every morning in the mirror
so cosmo doesn't really like kofax right
now
cosmos by 14 month old kofax is 20
months and kofax is like this bumbling
sort of happy jolly monster like a
gentle giant and doesn't know his own
strength and cosmo and his past life was
a daisy
and i swear he's gonna be a poet
laureate one day or something like he's
just a sensitive soul and they're they
don't always click but sometimes they do
but kovacs really try i know like he'll
come up and be like hi camo and he comes
up and he's like gently about to touch
him and come ex is like cosmo cosmos
literally looks like he's about to get
attacked and just shrinks into this like
please don't hurt me but it's so special
to have the cousin relationship because
we were never close with our cousins
like yeah geologic geographically yeah
well we're they're not geographically
close either that's my point it's like
they're they're not close and so we
never really got to
yeah but since we see each other all the
time
and they tr like it's so cute because we
do see moments we're like oh they're
playing together it's so sweet
and my eldest like love playing with
cosmo and just love babies like my two
oldest kids especially just love taking
care of babies so they just will sloop
cosmo up and take care of them so we can
like you know do the dishes or whatever
and it's just so nice yes definitely
so where should we begin we have so many
things to talk about no it was really
hard to decide what we were gonna talk
about i think um i i love so many topics
it's hard i feel like i don't really
have a exact
niche
and so i just have you know i'm
passionate about yoga and veganism but
beyond that just general positive
mindset and relationships and living a
fulfilled life and everything and i
don't know it's you take you take the
reins it was just hard to narrow it down
because we're like what specific thing
would people like to hear is just chat
about so we kind of have like a
like just i feel like it's just gonna go
a lot of different places and i'm okay
with that i really love organic
conversation yeah and i think it gets
interesting when we're willing to get a
little vulnerable
and don't have an exact plan you know
what i mean yeah totally well i feel
like
it would be interesting to talk a little
bit about like
childhood and growing up and our
friendship and how it has evolved so
much because a lot of people do see us
and they know we're so close yeah and
how
it became that way like what's your
we're really lucky i feel because i not
everyone i know is this close with their
sisters and we always comment like i
can't imagine not having this
relationship it's been so formative for
me and for you and i would just be a
completely different person if it
weren't for you i know i feel the same
way and whenever i come across people
say i'm not really close to my sister or
my sibling i'm just like
how like it's hard for me to understand
because i've only had one experience
with one sister
um but i think i wonder how much of it
has to do with like
um just like personality dynamics and
differences yeah or if it's like i don't
know i don't know i mean it's the way we
were raised in our household the way our
parents raised us and um we fought it's
not like we've always been and we still
fight we still bicker all the time we're
sisters yeah like there's honestly when
we're like getting on each other's
nerves it's like but we always just like
work it out and talk it through and i
think it doesn't go it has to do with
like open
communication we don't allow each other
to hide or to avoid yeah because if
they're i'm for real because i think a
lot of families are so accustomed to
hiding and putting on this pretty face
and pretending everything's okay and
they're not going to talk about the hard
things
and one of my favorite things about our
family in general not to mention just
our relationship is how we really do get
in there and we're just so we are so
direct let me give you an example
when um my husband eric my husband when
eric first uh
one of his first times coming to our
house my family house you were living
here so you weren't there but he had
dinner with our parents
and
he was so unaccustomed to the way i
talked to my parents like
we were raised
to
be respectful to everyone
but just because they're my parents it
doesn't mean i can't
be direct with them and they treat me
like i'm my own person and i can have my
own ideas yeah our own opinions we can
have our own opinions and i can broach
those opinions and i can push back a
little bit and i remember my mom said
something and i i don't know what i said
but something direct back like you know
maybe a little snotty and eric turns me
he's like hannah you can't talk to like
you can't talk like that to your mom
we're in our 20 late 20s he's like you
can't talk like that to your mom i was
like what i've never been told that i
can't
speak my mind
yeah and it reminds me of another
situation too where i was at
i was visiting and you and eric were
already married um and we had we were
sitting down at the table and we were
having some kind of debate slash
discussion on something we disagreed
with and
i think it was about like uh
getting paid like certain professions
and how much you should be getting paid
like something really funny just random
and we were just like going back and
forth about it and like feeling strongly
about it and then you know eric is like
why are you guys fighting and we're like
this is for like fighting
this isn't fighting oh you want to see
fighting
no it's not like we fight but you know
what i mean like
that's just um speaking our mind and
being okay with talking about things
that are a little uncomfortable
and um i i think that the more we talk
about that because we talk about this
topic a lot because i find it really
interesting
i think that so many people just weren't
raised to
speak their mind and to be comfortable
with disagreement because and this well
let me just bring it back to your
podcast ellen i this is what your
podcast is like you you're ready to dig
into some really uncomfortable topics
that might ruffles definitely ruffle
some feathers and um you're right i'm
just so proud of what you're creating
because i feel like i don't know if your
audience is really aware of what you're
doing and this sort of
big sort of thesis you're orchestrating
it's like you're setting up so many
interesting topics in an open-minded way
and bringing in people from all
different backgrounds and all different
perspectives and having just fun
conversations with people who are
willing to
dig into it and i'm just so proud of
what you're doing because i don't see
very many people taking that pivot
especially from like you know youtube
influencer lifestyle vlogger a little
vanilla right like you're not ruffling
any feathers and then
hey you know what this is what i'm
passionate about and this is what i'm
doing and i'm just so proud of you and i
can't wait to see it just completely
take off and and see which way it's
gonna go
thank you i yeah some people might be
kind of like i wish you would have just
stuck to what you knew and i'm like
sorry this is where i feel like going
it's not it's not up to them what you do
yeah and i'm just going in the direction
that i'm excited about and there's only
so much that i can
share on uh you know my main channel and
i was really looking to like explore in
a lot of different topics i really
anyone listening i encourage you to go
listen to my dominic thompson episode
that one was so good and kind of
highlights something what you're talking
about just like digging into a lot of
different
layers and important topics and
like even differing perspectives like
that was not a
by any means an opposing views episode
at all like
literally so much most of what we talked
about was what what we we kind of
aligned on um there was a part like
towards the end where we get like okay
i'm not sure i agree on this and i just
like love that to me it's like my
favorite thing like certain aspects we
can just go back and forth and listen to
each other and that's like how i'm being
very careful on who i have onto the
podcast is like
specific people who are very open-minded
and
i'm just so inspired by so many people
out there and i just like i'm so excited
to have them on the podcast i'm just
really inspired by this show right now
so thank you everyone for tuning in well
absolutely i mean if you just keep doing
the same thing over and over you know
you might say if it ain't broke don't
fix it however if your passion is
flagging and you're not actually
excited about the content you're
producing the audience picks up on that
and i think this is a really common
theme with influencers in all medium in
media they uh really burn out and then
the audience loses interest and you're
doing something really daring and
exciting which i think is so important
to what's going on in our culture right
now because
you you're not just like i don't know
it's not this black and white sort of
cut and dried
show it's it's everything i think it
could come across that way for maybe
someone who like sees the title and
doesn't feel like watching it or
something um but i think for people who
are willing to just like give it a
chance and listen they might see there's
a lot more layers and nuance to like
every conversation no nuance that is
what and that's my point is that's what
we're all craving right now is nuance
and and getting away taking a break from
the divisiveness and just getting into
the black and white there's so many
black and white like people having the
black and white polarization like
hitting people against each other yes
which i really don't like and anyone
who's listened to any amount of episodes
my podcast is like all right ellen yeah
you've said that multiple times
um but just even bringing it back to
driving it back to the home about to the
topic of like our childhood like mom i
don't think i realized until i became an
adult like how
i feel like our parents were like
practicing gentle parenting before that
was a thing
and they really were have always been
respectful about our
perspectives and that was really huge
for us like growing up and
i hope to instill that in my family too
i try my very best to anything that i'm
passionate about or remotely have an
interest in to be like this is what i
feel this is what i'm thinking not like
labeling this is what we feel as a
family because like i don't know what my
child's gonna feel as they get older
they might not have the same opinions on
me on a lot of things as i get older so
i really hope to
instill that
safety within the kids to know that like
you can have you can think what you want
to think and i love that you use the
word safety because yeah that's an
interesting word for it i guess no i
think it's great because you can feel
secure
in disagreement and i think that we you
know sometimes the safe place safe space
whatever that gets overused it's like
i'm only safe if everyone agrees with
you yes oh i'm so not about that yeah no
i agree that's such a good point because
safety should be
like just acknowledging that you can be
who you are think what you want to think
and share how you feel without this like
fear of being quote unquote cancelled or
labeled as like this this or this you
know
so yeah i think that that's really
a really interesting dynamic about the
way that we were raised and yeah
we definitely fought we definitely as a
kid
as children there were like you said you
don't have that many memories of our
childhood
yeah what memories do you have okay i
remember once either you or me
like we would use our nails a lot when
we fly is that like a girl thing did we
just remember
i think it was me i dug made i'm just
gonna say it was me i dug my nails into
you your shoulders and you're wearing
tank top like drag you no i would never
do that i'm so kind of exaggerating
about how extreme our friendship is
right now hannah we thought as kids and
i remember we have memories of yeah um
us fighting and
mom having you know
a group downstairs or something and then
we go up she goes up what are you guys
doing we're working it out like we're
we're people and mom this was something
that my mom has actually said to me
multiple times like when you guys were
fighting i would just say go to your
room and work it out instead of like
yeah trying to dedicate someone out to
be the bad guy or the good guy
and i do remember us being like going to
our room and then just eventually i'm
sorry it's so good for kids to learn how
to like it's okay to be angry and it's
okay to have these like big emotions but
you can work it out you know yeah and
there's obviously more layers to it
there's a lot of situations it really
depends on the situation but the way
that we were
was just kind of i don't know like we
would just fight over the silliest thing
but i do remember because i think that
we are so close now and
i don't know if that would have happened
if it hadn't been for
me moving away a couple times yeah why
did we get close and when did we get
close so i went i started school um in
orange county i didn't like the school
so then i went to oregon and i was there
for a semester i remember as soon as i
left it was like oh my sister and we
sort of
realized what we had yeah and then we
you know were communicating and however
people communicated back in 2007
and probably by email or text and then
i'm tripping out right now oh like
regular cell phones just not like a
smartphone yeah i was like
what was it yeah you tapped them a lot
i was so good at t9 um and then
and then again after i graduated i went
to italy for a few months and i remember
having a lot of skype conversations with
you
and um we got a lot of practice in how
to be there for each other when we were
in the same time zone yeah and i think
it helped us like you said we realized
that oh like this is my person that's
there for me no matter what because you
go far away and you're like wait i don't
really have anybody right now so when i
need somebody
or i just want someone to help me talk
through something or i'm feeling big
emotions like who do you go to and like
you call your sister and that was like
that's probably one of the things that
helped realize how close we were yeah we
didn't realize available
um you know i've had questions before
about like well how like how do you guys
stay close even though you're so far
away like we pretty much
yeah we pretty much like call each other
facetime text each other every day i
love when i wake up in the morning and i
have a text from my sister because my
time zone is later than her so she gets
up before me and when i you know turn
off airplane mode i have a text from my
sister you're always the first person
that i'm looking at the text and
even though i don't get on my phone
throughout the day i often don't answer
people's text messages until the end of
the day when the kids are asleep um but
you're someone that it's like
we make the time for even during the day
especially if we need each other for
something and or just not even
necessarily like need each other but
like i'm having these big emotions or
i'm feeling frustrated right now can you
just can you talk to me for a few
minutes that's a need and i i think that
we always can we can sense when the
other person is busy and if you're too
busy and it's not that important okay
that's fine we'll talk later but if it's
like no hand helen i need you i really
need you right now yeah you communicate
that please step away and talk to me for
five minutes yeah and it's normally more
than five minutes but
yeah that's true but yeah i think that's
kind of just how we handle our
relationship and just make sure like
when i'm visiting california and seeing
you most of the time it's
the main reason why i'm visiting you
whereas andrew for him it's like the
rest of his family
yeah and stuff like that yeah and i i
think that growth in relationships uh
just happens through a lot of talking
for me at least we just talk a lot yeah
and openness and honesty and we we have
so many similarities and thoughts you
know i actually wanted to ask you this
and i this is perfect it's happening on
the podcast do you feel like you can
relate to me more now that i'm a mom
because
it's such a huge shift in who you are
when you become a mother for the first
time
and you know
we have we had a lot of similar life
things but motherhood was a huge missing
piece that we didn't share
until a year ago well i don't know
for you specifically i think for a lot
of people that is the case okay but i
don't know if for you specifically
because
you were there with me
you've been there for me so much through
the thick of like young motherhood and
new children and stuff that i really did
have always felt like you understood
okay i didn't but okay
you didn't really totally understand so
there were definitely like once you
became a mother that i would be like you
get it now like you see like it was the
moment when i was like ellen when do i
work out like when
do i exercise and you're like ah you
understand now you'll figure it out
you're just gonna squeeze it in
somewhere yeah you know so
there's definitely been moments where
i'm like yeah you get it now like
especially like with your home birth and
being like when the baby was born i'm
looking at you like see
isn't this incredible i remember before
i gave birth and you were so excited for
me you were more excited than i was like
i just was just excited to not be
pregnant anymore like i don't want to be
pregnant anymore i'm so tired of this
and you were like
hannah a slithery baby's going to come
out of your vagina it's going to be
amazing i'm like okay calm down and and
yeah i'm literally i was just like
you're just like uh-huh i'm like no no
hannah like really it's gonna be so
incredible like this otherworldly
experience and you're just gonna be on
this cloud like i'm so excited for you
and you're like uh-huh and then when the
baby's born you look at me with this
like
huge wine and like what the heck just
happened right now and i'm like see i
know it was i can't wait to do it again
it was amazing so that aspect and
certain parenting aspect things like
this like sleep and just like finding
time to do things and you know thinking
feeling like you were busy before you
had a kid and then now if you have a kid
be like oh
okay this is busy but that's not to like
discount anyone she doesn't have it's a
different kind of busy it's a different
kind of busy it also depends on your
lifestyle like everyone can feel busy
depending on what they're doing like i
know i feel like ellen business is such
a thing for me that i want to let go of
i don't want to be that person where
every time someone asks me how i'm doing
and i just say i'm so busy oh my gosh i
do that i've been that person for a
decade and i'm tired of it i definitely
do that when people are like how are you
i'm like good just busy we have a lot
going on you know we've got this going
on we're doing this guy like we're
homeschooling the kids and this this is
i'm almost always busy is the word i
know and i
i definitely feel like slowing down and
not like labeling yourself as like this
is my identity i think this business is
helpful it can be a perspective
yeah and and it's it's like an intention
on like how much you're doing in your
life and just being willing to slow down
because it can be hard sometimes to slow
down when you feel like you have so many
things on your list
that just haven't get done and i'm
definitely the type of person where
i like to check everything off before i
relax because i can relax so much better
if everything is checked off my list but
when you're raising children it is not
necessarily best for
your mental well-being or theirs if
you're just obsessed with getting
everything checked off before you hang
out with them oh yeah you know like
because if you're like look i'm gonna
just forget the dishes the house looks
like a tornado came through it well
we're just gonna sit down here and play
a board game and do this or that or play
baseball or whatever and not feel like
oh yeah we'll do that after i do this we
got a lot to do still we're doing this
so i got work to do you know just like
pause i just chill children exist on a
different plane like they don't see it
they don't see the urgency of
getting everything done and so when they
want to play with you
and you say i can't right now it's like
a kind of a huge disappointment
often yeah i feel like it's so helpful
to show your excitement and your
enthusiasm for wanting to play with your
children even if you can't play with
them right in the moment you know
i really do want to do that yes that's a
great idea let me just finish this up
and then we'll do that or as often as
you can to just yes set down whatever
you're doing and just do it because like
you're never going to get those years
back i know like those years when
they're so little and they want to do
everything with you and i think it's a
daily reminder of just
treasuring and cherishing those
beginning years because i have to
constantly remind myself it's just a
it's a bad habit of mine where i just am
constantly
obsessed with productivity
but do you feel like you've worked on it
in any way hugely
i do think though sometimes the things
on the to-do list that i have to check
off are self-care things
it gets it gets outrageous it's like all
right time to do my vaginal weight
lifting check
facial exercises check skin care roller
like
three hours later i'm walking out of the
bathroom you know like it's just
ridiculous yeah it's definitely it's
it's a decision on like what's worth it
to you like you know just deciding what
do i have time for today yeah and what's
my biggest priority and so lifting your
vagina while rolling your skin at the
same like multitasking i've become quite
a multitasker yeah putting on my makeup
at the same time
yeah there's like
but it really does come down to like
just the priority of spending time with
your children and so when it comes to
the other things that you have going on
it is a daily reminder to be like let it
go not everything has to get done today
yeah no not just the self-care stuff but
the work stuff i know yeah and the
productivity like
it's been a huge journey for me where i
didn't realize it was such an obsession
and
a bad thing i just always associated
productivity as positive
and not really realizing i was really
immersed in this culture of how to get
things done get more done you know do
more every day and
it just it ruined my sleep it ruined my
just stress level my anxiety it was not
good for me and
i think i need to sort of do a little
bit of a reset since you know i'm now
out of that first year of motherhood
which was intense and i feel like i can
do more of a
settling back into
i don't know
yeah i think that balance is so
huge because if you're too not about
productivity versus too too much about
the productivity you know they could be
thrown out of balance either way so
the balance is key and so maybe you can
talk a little about your kind of
passions in like living a fulfilling
life your mindset yeah stuff you read a
book that really helped you okay let me
tell you the story you're like really
passionate i am it's something i can't
stop like you know that thing where
they're like what's that thing you can't
stop talking about for me it's mindset
because i've had i'm continuing to have
a radical transformation
for me mostly the topic was finances
because of where i was to where i am now
is just a huge huge journey and
basically i was a teacher i got my
degree in english my bachelor's and then
i was teaching esl and i realized hey if
i want this other job at a community
college i need to get my master's got my
master's got into some student loan debt
and um
and then just was working jobs and i
became what they call a freeway flyer
which is basically trying to
fill enough classes into your schedule
to make up a full income to live in
southern california and it's very
expensive in california and they don't
pay teachers very well so i was just
sort of stuck in this position and i
just sort of thought
i would always
have that level of income
which is fine you know i could have been
fine on that but i realized that i
actually desired more
of something bigger and let me let me
insert here actually because it's kind
of awkward to talk about finances and
money in general because everyone has
different experiences
is that i had basically a very poor
relationship with money it was like i
wanted it but i felt guilty for wanting
it and i felt like it was
wrong to be rich and wrong or rich in
quotes whatever that means to each
person wrong to desire wealth i wanted
to make more but i i kept telling myself
that i couldn't even though i was
already doing
my own thing online having a podcast and
i was doing youtube and stuff
then one day my friend cami pettin
showed this book on her insta stories
called you are a badass at making money
and i found that title
really offensive
you know like i just found it very
glaring
it was very triggering for me i was like
you're not supposed to say that on the
cover of a book and i ordered it because
i thought why not it just sounded really
radical to me and so
i was oh you know i was listening to it
that's what it was i was listening to it
as chopping veggies and i had to stop
because the book felt like it was really
written for me and it was about like
telling yourself how you're always going
to have this much money or whatever and
um it's like you're repelling money
it's like whoa i had to pause it because
that was just every i everything to me
and after i read that book in three
months i tripled my income and all i did
was shift my mind you know and shift my
mind about money and i and
what it is it's like deep gratitude and
how did it also shift the way you made
choices in your life but that's where it
started right that's where it starts
because if i was so determined to
make this level of income
then i would never have gone after
because i would get i
realized i was getting emails i was
getting money was trying to come to me
and i was saying no isn't that so
bizarre i think you can't relate this is
not your story at all but like a lot of
people have this story i know i have
close people in my life who
they still are like well i can never
afford that i'll never be able to do
that well i'm always going to be
divorced
when she says i can't relate to it
because it's not my story it really
isn't my story i've never had that kind
of mindset where like oh i can't i'm
never going to be able to make this or
that kind of mindset
but what i have found really helpful is
what you're saying the mindset of like i
can do this and what can i do
to be successful at whatever we're
wanting to do whether that's about money
or not whether that's about where we
want to live or not like a lot of people
don't really know andrew and i's story
and what we did to make living here work
for us and how when we moved here
i didn't want to go back to work because
i didn't want to go back to being a
waitress and so i wanted to be at home
with my son and i had one kid at the
time and andrew was like yeah i'm on
board with that so when we moved here he
got two jobs as a zip line um tour guide
and then he also became
a grocery store employee at a health
food store and he worked about 60 hours
a week just to make sure that we could
meet our requirements to not
dip into our savings because we wanted
to make sure we could continue to save
and we had these goals for a home yeah
to buy our first home so we had these
goals and so we lived extremely
minimally about the got the cheapest
rent we could find from a house that was
really run down it was rough over there
really run down but to us it was worth
it because we're like we don't want to
be spending more than we can afford we
don't want to be spending more just
because we would live in a more
quote-unquote nicer looking house
to us it was worth it to make that
sacrifice and so while that was
strugglesome for us like just moving
here and not really knowing anybody and
then like working so much we kind of
have that mindset of like
short-term
short-term hard work for long-term gains
that's kind of the mindset and i have
always had so like we knew that that was
on the horizon for us and we knew we
could get there but um it was about hard
work and personal responsibility and
that was like a really big thing for us
and then that's when like organically
just sharing my life online just became
something and i'm like oh i should do
something with this and you've never had
that limiting mindset i don't know
that's something that you and i differ
yeah you know
you've always been but what's funny is a
sure of yourself in that way yeah but
what's funny is i don't ever remember
being like hannah you're limiting
yourself i never felt like that about
you like i never was like hannah you can
be like i don't think we've ever had
talks like that yeah you totally said
that did i yeah okay i don't know you're
like hannah i'd be like
just feeling sorry for myself all the
time i can't believe i was like that
constantly just like ellen you're so
lucky like you can do this i'm stuck in
this job and you're like hannah you're
already making videos like why can't you
create a business for yourself yeah or
like make a recipe ebook and i was like
encouraging i was like i can't do i just
i had an excuse for everything and this
is why i'm so passionate about it
because i i hear other people say that
and i see my past self in them and so
with their permission i give them free
life coaching
okay but to be clear that's not to say
that like anyone who has who is
struggling with making an income is
necessarily just like oh you just need
to flip your mind like there's different
situations yeah that i feel like there's
different situations for so many
different types of
like
places in life that people are at that
like
i don't know it takes sometimes it takes
more than that and there's a lot and so
it starts there i'm with you i know
you're trying to be really nice to
people right now but like i'm like
listen like it starts there obviously
everyone's comes from a different
background everyone has different like
yes yeah but
for many many people
if you can start to feel extreme
gratitude for where you are now
and what you know is coming because if
you can desire it it means that you're
desiring it for a reason there's nothing
wrong with desiring more for your life
and i that was pivotal for me because i
thought i was felt guilty for wanting
more right
i'm so with you right there i think that
our mindset is huge personal
responsibility is huge and not like
blaming others yes but i also think it's
also really helpful just to preface and
laying the groundwork of this type of
conversation that like some people are
in really really really tough situations
that it is
they're starting at a different place
that it's harder to get to like a place
that maybe someone else is getting to so
just i don't know just acknowledge no i
get that and i and you know there's i
always get the email of like you don't
understand my situation and sure i don't
understand your situation because i'm
not you
but i do know
so many people in my life that
are don't they don't realize how
determined they are to stay in their
situation
they are determined to be miserable yeah
and it also it just goes to show that
like for whatever hard situation that
someone is going through there's
somebody else that has gone through a
very similar situation and has pulled
themselves through it and to be kind
said about it yeah it has become this
incredible overwhelming success in all
facets of life this is not just about
money but yeah just about just about
success in whatever you feel like it's
success i i think dominic thompson is a
perfect example that like you guys
really should go listen to that episode
his story is so incredible he's very
inspiring all the stuff he overcame and
it really comes down to like making a
choice to take your chances when you get
it and to
to go for it and to have that mindset
switch is huge and so part of that too
is how we raise our kids if we're
raising our kids to think that like you
won't be able to do this or that and
like it'll be too hard like i think it's
like generational trauma i know that
like makes it hard to break that cycle
sometimes well it's interesting i don't
know like how much we can share but
about our own parents like they did not
come from money
yeah actually i was having a
conversation with dominic i keep
bringing him up but we had such a great
time with him visiting and we were just
talking about kind of our life stories
and stuff and i was just telling him a
little bit about like my parents
background and he's like you should talk
about that more
and now a word from our sponsors
as a mom it's important to me to use
products that are both effective and
made without harmful ingredients and it
always feels good to use products that
cut down on waste too did you know that
an estimated five billion plastic hand
soap and cleaning bottles are thrown
away each year and if that's not bad
enough each bottle can be made of more
than 90 water
what a waste enter blue land with blue
land you buy a bottle once and refill it
forever no more plastic waste what a
simple and beautiful idea the only thing
you need to discard is your outdated
idea that eco-friendly products are more
expensive and less effective just fill
blue lands forever bottles with warm
water pop in one of the hand soap or
spray cleaner tablets and within minutes
you have powerful cleaning products in
the most incredible sense like iris
agave and lavender eucalyptus i used to
have trouble finding effective but
eco-conscious cleaning products not
anymore i've been using blueland's clean
essentials kit as a regular part of my
cleaning routine for months now and
absolutely love it and i also recently
got their plastic free laundry and
dishwasher tablets so blueland has
something for all your cleaning needs
the forever bottles start at just ten
dollars a bottle when you buy a kit and
are meant to be reused forever with
money-saving refill tablets that start
at just two dollars and right now you
can get 20 off your first order when you
go to blueland.com
ellen that's 20 off your first order of
any blueland products at blueland.com
ellen blueland.com
ellen we're also brought to you today by
buffy getting a good night's sleep is so
important for our physical and mental
well-being buffy enhances my quality of
sleep with their incredibly soft and
sustainable bedding helping to reset
from busy days balancing work and being
a mom
so what's so great about buffy is that
the bedding industry typically has a
huge impact on the environment but they
decided to change that their products
are made using only renewable and
recycled materials which makes them as
soft on the planet as they are on your
bed
and you guys their cloud comforter is
incredible it has over eighteen thousand
five star reviews and is definitely the
best comforter i've ever slept with the
cloud comforter is ultra breathable
softer than cotton and keeps you at the
perfect temperature to feel cozy without
overheating it's covered in super soft
eucalyptus fabric and filled with fluffy
fiber made from 100 recycled bottles
it's hypoallergenic plus its high thread
count shuts out dust mold and mites for
a healthier sleep environment
the most important aspect of this
comforter for me is that the average
down comforter harms 12 geese but
buffy's comforter is cruelty free it
feels even softer than down while
keeping about 50 bottles out of
landfills and oceans and eucalyptus uses
10 times less water than cotton to grow
so use my code ellen for twenty dollars
off orders over eighty dollars you can
dry comforter in your own bed for free
if you don't love it return it at no
cost
mom and dad do not they love everything
whenever they hear themselves in the
pocket she's like that's me i heard you
talked about me on the podcast and she's
like i taught you how to make the veggie
broth yeah
she's like always excited when she gets
brought up mom and dad we love you yeah
they're our biggest fans so yeah biggest
fans my by the way guys my dad is like
the most amazing affirmer like and that
is if a lot of you might know that after
me words of affirmation is definitely my
love language and so my dad has just
always been that way our dad he'll send
us the longest messages like with
details and specific
things about something he's affirming
like i just watched your last podcast
and like you are just so incredible i'm
so amazed by you and your growth and
like i love the way you talked about
this or this and like i've like he has
always said like i've always felt like i
don't deserve you guys like he's just
just so expresses so much gratitude for
us and he's just i've always felt so
loved by him because he has been so
incredible with his words i was going
somewhere with this why did we ring my
nose
well let me say that mom is also
extremely loving yeah
they're both incredible she feeds us
all day long and that is how she shows
us love and i feel very and and after i
had a baby i was so glad i lived 15
minutes from my mom because even for
five months later she's still bringing
dinner over to me like bring it on and
bring the upset the enchiladas there
thank you very much that support is so
helpful i remember what i was going to
say is um dominic i was telling him kind
of like an apparent story he's like you
should share more of that online i think
like a lot of people would like to kind
of know that like those different
generations of you know what's going on
like my dad our our dad grew up in a
trailer park and had um alcoholic
parents and he just had his childhood
was definitely like a
more traumatic type of childhood where
he was determined to not become that as
an adult he was like i that is not gonna
be me when i grow up i'm gonna make
something of myself and he was so
determined to just be like
he just had so much incredible personal
responsibility get out of his situation
and he did and this is what i love about
dad's story is that he studied
philosophy at humboldt state
[Music]
such a hippie
philosophy humble state yeah and um and
then
he ended up working as a drafter at an
engineering firm like
you couldn't get a more opposite sort of
career right
and then he sort of worked his way up to
one day
he's owning the company and he is
studying for his life this is this is
the biggest thing he got his engineering
license without having an engineering
degree which is very uncommon and he's
stuck you remember during childhood like
he took that test like five times or
something and it was studying so hard
super difficult it's an incredibly
difficult task most people don't pass
the first time and they have engineering
degrees see what i'm saying like he had
to really put in the work and he did it
and i'm just so proud of him oh my gosh
especially when he would tell us about
his child and what he came through came
from yeah we're like i was always just
kind of shocked to hear about it because
he literally changed his life to such a
degree that when he raised his own
children we didn't have to go through we
wanted nothing we didn't yeah it was
like he
changed his trajectory of his life he
was determined to get out of that
situation of growing up in a trailer
park having like a hard childhood and
being like this is not going to be my
life when i grow up and so as he became
older he literally like kind of broke
that type of
generational thing that can often happen
and as a result we were so like
totally different yeah
privileged type of growing up because of
his determination and personal
responsibility which i think is an
incredible story and dad's story doesn't
end there because he is on this like
constant transformation i feel like he
would be i feel like i should get him on
the podcast let me know in the comments
if you guys want to get see my dad
gary on here yeah he's just
been working on himself for the past few
years he went plant based a couple years
ago and automatically it was like he was
reverse aging like yeah he just looked
incredible and was he was doing like
paleo high meat height like animal
products before grass-fed stuff yeah and
then he
switched to plant base and when what it
was is when eric and i moved in there
for a year and a half to save money to
own a home and he saw how much i was
eating and he's like oh i have to eat
that much i'm like yeah you gotta eat
more than me you're a tall man yeah you
know
actually a lot of people are like wait
that's so cool that your parents are
about the plant mate based now we should
talk a little bit about
that because
hannah and i have been vegan for a long
time have been been vegan for 15 years
wait do you feel like that's the exact
amount of time for you as well well yeah
i've been vegan for 15 years the first
six years were a while a little bit
up and down which i think is relatable
most people don't have an overnight easy
transition yeah um
so for me it was we're just different we
just have totally different
personalities
for me it was easy for me
we have very different personalities but
wait can we pause real quick though
because
i do want to say that the transition
into being fully plant-based for me it
was like
i thought i was struggling because i
lacked discipline i thought i thought
there was something wrong with me and
ellen just was a more disciplined person
and that's why you could do it which is
so so false and i just i'm determined to
dismantle that because and that's why
your course is so incredible we should
talk about that and then i also want to
get back to mom and dad okay plant-based
but talk about your course because i
think you you from your story is really
helpful you have this life experience
that can and is helping people to
transition to being vegan and to
not only doing it for life like for life
but also for the good of everything like
for your health and the planet and
animals so just talk about like what
your course is for anyone interested and
i will link below
anyone interested in checking out her
course if you're interested in going
plant-based or you're interested let's
say you've been dabbling with eating
plant-based vegan and you're like i
would just like some more guidance on um
just how to make it stick yeah and and
make it stick yes but i love the word
sustainable because it's like let's make
this a lifestyle i know it's so overused
in the diet world like it's a lifestyle
yeah it's like literally every diet
these days is like it's not a diet it's
a lifestyle
yeah that's pretty much every diet now
but you know i will i do think whole
food plant-based is is a it's more than
a diet well if you're eating whole foods
well that's if you're eating like if
you're living a vegan lifestyle if
you're like eating whole foods
plant-based for your health it is kind
of considered like a dietary pattern
sure but if you're doing this as like a
lifestyle habit for
the multitude of reasons that it is to
me that's a life well i think the word
diet often seems like it's temporary
yeah so that's the thing why i created
the vegan for good course is that
we see people go vegan and stop being
vegan all the time and people have been
going vegan it's not being vegan for
centuries because this diet has been
around for a very long time and
i'm over my years of being vegan myself
knowing people who go vegan stay vegan
or stop being vegan and being on in the
online space like i've learned a lot
about what's going on and i really
wanted to set up a course that really
holds people's hands and
gives them it's not just information
like this is
a full program that is tailored for you
and it's not
um just for one type of person
and it can be for someone who went vegan
and then they stopped it's this is who
it's really for someone who went vegan
then stopped you know and they want to
go vegan again like let's let's make
this let's make this work this time yeah
and just help you with sustainable
lifestyle shifts yes that's the
difference it's not a temporary diet it
is a sustainable lifestyle shift so that
you are thriving because that's what it
feels like for us like literally it is
like the back of our hand second nature
busy now it's easy it's sustainable i
feel incredible my health is driving my
family's health is thriving and there's
reasons for that because there's lots of
different ways to eat vegan and not all
of them are healthy yeah that's just the
reality and then there's also different
ways to do it it's not just about like
what you're eating sure yeah and we dig
a lot into nutrition and i worked with
some registered dietitians james and
dolly and marin from married to health
they're marvelous you should definitely
check them out and i wanted to work with
some people who were really credible
because i'm not a nutritionist okay this
is not a nutritionist course but
nutrition is a really big aspect
obviously but we also really dig into
the mindset thing because this is huge
you're making a dramatic shift in your
life and you're like how am i how am i
going to handle social situations how i
just feel like i can't be vegan or what
about like my partner doesn't want to
eat plant-based with me yeah or even
even if you're just like okay i want to
eat more plant-based and i want to do it
healthfully like this this is a great
course yeah absolutely are people who
are already vegan and they're like i'm
ready to be fully whole foods
plant-based and really get rid of the
junk get rid of the processed foods and
go more into the healthy healthy
stuff and so i can feel my best and
because honestly if you feel good it's
you're going to thrive you're going to
keep doing it yeah if you're eating
stuff that's subpar and just sort of
getting lazy with that that's not going
to make it sustainable yeah and to
preface too it doesn't mean that you're
never going to eat something processed
for something that's not you know
optimal quality that's going to just be
like magic for your insides but it is
helpful to get into this habit of the
way that you're living where the
majority of the foods that you're eating
that you're excited to eat is whole
plant foods and then the stuff that's
you know on the side is just like the
fun every once in a while when you're
with your friends or whatever um
make those peripheral foods you know
it's and it's not about perfection and
being vegan i think people think like
well i can't call myself vegan because
i'm not a perfect vegan there's no such
thing as a perfect vegan there's no such
thing as a perfect diet there's no such
thing as well i would feel so much
better if i just didn't eat gluten
anymore you know like there's so many
factors to well-being and health that we
can't isolate them just to this meal i
ate one time made me feel this way right
totally it's like health is so much more
than just what you're eating yeah i love
how in the course you're talking about
like a lot of different specific topics
that people tackle with and you want to
name like a few well a big one is my
partner or family is not vegan like the
people you live with you know and how do
i handle that and i have first hand
experience because my husband and i have
been married i think nine years now nine
years yeah and he is not vegan and i am
shocked guys i thought he'd be vegan by
now like right why is he vegan i don't
know but that's his choice okay it's his
journey and yeah and
journey yes because
he has come a long way
he eats so many plants now he eats
almost exclusively vegan he's pretty
much 100 vegan at home and then when he
goes out you know he'll have whatever he
wants but sometimes he goes out and he
does choose vegan a lot of people don't
know too that when andrew and i were
dating as we started dating we were 15
and 16 i became plant-based when i was
19 and i came over he like he met me at
my house and i like pulled up because i
was somewhere else i forget why but i
pulled up and he was already there i'm
like babe i'm gonna go vegan and he's
like what
what are you talking about so we weren't
married yet but we were dating and i was
like yeah i'm so excited he's like
you're not gonna eat milk and i was like
no he's like you're not gonna have eggs
nope you're not gonna eat meat no i'm
like i'm gonna eat this and this and
this and all these things i wanna eat
i'm so excited i got these books and i'm
just like so pumped and he's like
okay he's like that's fine but don't
expect me to do it i'm like that's okay
i don't even care i'm just doing it for
my own house for me but slowly over time
it was it was when we there was like
differences that he started to see he
saw
you know he would go get an in-n-out
burger and i would eat a big salad and
i'd be like oh man i feel so great and
he's like oh
i did not feel great i'm like well why
do you think that is you know so towards
lee over over time especially when we
got married
that's when he started wanting to
wanting to dabble with like green
smoothies and he would just start making
more of his own plant foods and his
journey was also transferred and i think
he had such successes because you didn't
push him yeah i didn't and i pushed real
hard ellen like i really encourage
people to just stop pushing not only is
it making it literally worse they are
you're pushing them away from being
vegan it's also just not good for your
relationship no and once i stopped
pushing it took me a while you know
maybe the first one to two years in our
marriage we struggled it was hard i'm
not gonna say it was all easy
but after i just went you know what
eric can do what he wants yeah that's
like part of unconditional love is like
loving each other for our differences of
opinions and choices it's beyond just
being vegan i had to let go with wanting
to change him in any way yeah and you
know what i i'm gonna speak a little bit
to people who are like um ethical vegans
here listening going yeah well that's
easy to say that but like you know your
partner or whatever is choosing to
support um like hurting animals and
abusing animals like i understand where
you're coming from but it's also really
helpful to just try to get in the brain
of someone else who doesn't think like
you and try to have empathy and realize
that while for you
and for a lot of people like other
vegans it's really easy to just go there
and be like well you can't you can't
just not judge someone or just not try
to change someone when they're doing
something that you believe is wrong or
that you're saying is wrong but try to
understand that everybody has their own
journey and put yourself in their brain
and tr and like it's not
it's not a good thing to not understand
what people think the way that they do
someone who thinks differently than you
that's not that's not something to be
proud of it's it's something to be proud
of is to be like i understand how you
got there i understand why you think
that way i disagree
but
you're there and that's what you think
yeah and um
i i feel like what people forget is that
they weren't always vegan either like
yeah i
and i can guarantee the first time you
heard about the idea of veganism you
were like i'm giving up animal products
right like it might have taken you some
time um and some people just take longer
and just and it's not even just some
people take long there's some people
listening here who are probably never
going to go plan and it's like people
just have different opinions and
different um perspectives through the
life experiences that they've gone
through and just like trying your best
here through everything through politics
through your lifestyle habits right to
just like understand that we're all
going through
our own journeys and um trying to figure
it out the best that we can and people
are gonna think well no i believe this
is healthy for me and i need this or
whatever and just like trying to
understand at least how they got there
and just having empathy with that i feel
like that is so key and really helpful
for your own mental health too to not
try to fix people or not trying to say
like everyone needs to live exactly like
me or think exactly like me because i
have all the answers it's really hard
because i know what's best for everyone
else just she's being prestigious guys
she's just she's being sarcastic
sometimes it's really hard to read her
humor i don't know it's hard for ellen
to read i've heard you learn over time
but there's times where you're making a
joke and i'm like oh yeah you joking
about how how do you have andrew for a
husband and you still don't know how to
read sarcasm it's not that i don't know
how to read it it's just i don't like it
like i'm like can you just can you just
like tell me how you like i don't know i
don't know i don't know i thought my
facetiousness worked really well there
anyway moving on no no it didn't no it's
not that i don't like that you did that
there i'm just saying like when people
like do sarcastic jokes i'm like wait
but there might be somebody in the room
who doesn't know you're being sarcastic
you care so much i appreciate it but no
i want to tell about the other topics in
my course because it's not just about
other if your partner isn't vegan we
also talk a lot about cheese addiction
because when i i did a random sort of
hey what's holding you back from being
vegan as i was creating the course and
literally half of the people responded
cheese though
cheese i'm addicted to cheese i do an
entire module about cheese i have an
entire really deep module about cravings
both like
craving non-vegan things and i'm vegan
but i'm craving junk
junk vegan food you know i want to eat
more whole foods and
we talk about grocery shopping you know
basics we talk about meal prepping and
cooking and how to make cooking not a
source of stress we cover so many things
and yeah i'm just so proud of it and i'm
so grateful for the community we're
building and the people who are emailing
me who are doing the course and taking
the course and just uh yeah they're
getting their vegan game changed and let
me just clear it up real quick if you
don't know what a digital course is it's
completely self-paced it's 100 online i
will not send you a test or a quiz and
it's it's completely up to you i do
recommend going through it kind of
slowly to let everything settle in
because it's a lot of information um and
yeah i think some people aren't familiar
with digital courses and how they work
yeah thanks for sharing all that anyone
interested check it below yes um so
i think before we pivot into the next
thing i want to talk about i do want to
finish our little conversation about mom
and dad going plant-based
um
so they actually their journey has been
such a like a long one like the majority
of us being time that we were
plant-based like they were like
okay like
we're not gonna do it but like they were
nice they were always like so supportive
and helpful and always making us
plant-based foods and stuff and it was
probably a couple was it a year ago or a
couple years ago when mom mom went vegan
in the pandemic well she
she listened to a dr clapper interview
on rich roll and something for her just
lit a fire in her like she was like oh
it was like a light bulb it's been
amazing so awesome she's so passionate
now she's like i'm trying to tell my
friends you know they have this and this
symptom well because she's almost 70 all
of her friends have are sick everyone is
sick they all have like a lot of health
issues going on and she's like seeing
her and dad like dad's transformation
like getting off of all of his
medications and um like thriving and
doing so well like you said it looked
like he was like
reverse aging and just seeing how
like well they're doing she's like i'm
trying to tell my friends and like you
know these sometimes they just don't
want to watch the documentaries and
stuff but she's just so passionate and
now it's almost like i'm like see mom
you know how passionate i was in the
very beginning like that's where you're
at right now and she's yes yeah i get it
yes yeah i know and she used to um i was
just telling you this the other day she
used to hate tofu almost on principle
like i don't eat tofu
i'm not vegan and
now she embraces it she loves tofu and
she loves getting creative in the
kitchen because food is just it's
another extension of who she is is
making food and she loves finding new
plant-based recipes and i just love how
open-minded our parents are because like
dad had messaged me like six months ago
like you know i can kind of see myself
buying a vegan leather belt sometimes
yeah like getting into the ethical side
the other yeah other aspects anyways but
okay moving forward i think we should
talk about something that is on a lot of
people's minds when it comes to the two
of us i mean i don't think that we're on
a ton of people's minds but like like
anyone ever thinks it's not
but a lot of people when they think of
us us together and being on like social
media stuff they want us to talk about
our supposed opposing views
of how we choose to have our children
online
and
it's it's easy i think for people to
think and it's understandable
why people think we have opposing views
about it
um but you guys we actually have like
the exact same view it's just that we
have come to slightly different we're on
different time frames and different
journeys
and like yeah why don't you just start
what you're thinking oh okay well
yeah i totally get why i get a thousand
questions a day we should probably
preface for anyone who doesn't know
that's listening um hannah doesn't show
her child's face online and so honestly
i feel like the conversation it's like
like you said you're like so over it at
this point no it's not that i'm over it
it's just like i feel like i've talked
about it three times in a really big way
like hey if you have a question about
this i've already answered it but i'm
still getting questions but you haven't
really addressed it and i've talked
about a little bit in like one or two
episodes on the podcast but if you're
not like really listening to everything
i'm talking about then yeah i haven't
made like a video about it i just like
i'm just doing what i feel is best and i
don't really need to like
tell everybody but i think it'd be good
for us to talk about yeah then i think
that's where it starts it's like
i
don't feel like anyone else is entitled
to give me either praise or criticism
about my parenting choices so while i
appreciate the support thanks but
ultimately i think it's every parent's
choice i don't feel that strongly about
it is the funny thing is yeah like if i
don't show my face therefore i think
anyone else my kid's face therefore i
think anyone else who shows their kids
faces is wrong like it's not that this
is because a lot of people think in
black and white people a lot of people
think in polar black and white okay you
don't show your kid's face online this
person ellen she does show her kids face
online therefore they must have opposing
views but the reality is guys when
hannah was pregnant with cosmo we were
like together discussing it and she was
like what am i gonna do i'm like what
should i do and like i'm like
encouraging her like yeah if like if
you're feeling any kind of twinge of
just like i shouldn't like maybe i don't
want to show my kid's face online and
just don't do it like we're both
understanding of each other's like just
exact moment of time that we're in and
like it literally so this is yeah this
is how i explain it is how i got to that
decision because if i had had cosmo five
years ago when i first started making
videos if i think it was five years ago
i would have shown him no question
because i didn't have a real
understanding of the internet
now that i have been the subject of
critical videos
a slew of critical comments like i uh a
horde of critical comments haters coming
to my page i got this taste of oh that's
the internet the internet is a cesspool
of humanity it's just like this weird
place where you find these pockets of
beauty and wonderful connection yes and
i love it and that's why i'm still doing
it but then there's a lot of nastiness
okay and i'm okay being the subject of
that because i have grown a thick skin
and i love who i am i'm very secure in
who i am you can say whatever you want
about me you are entitled to your own
opinion but your opinion actually has
nothing to do with me
my child however is off limits so i had
to find some sort of boundary where how
can i still be a lifestyle vlogger
i don't know any other lifestyle
vloggers who do this like every other
lifestyle vlogger shows their kid recipe
vloggers or political whatever yeah
it's different tied your kid that way
this is so awkward you guys i have to
show my life and sort of
cause your kid is your life your
children are your life he's attached to
me yeah maybe a little too attached
like
he's attached to me i literally have to
hire a babysitter so that i can film
because otherwise well not only will he
knock down my tripod but it's just i
can't show him and i've made that
decision eric and i came to that
decision together and um and through
your encouragement which is the irony
because people might assume that yeah
yeah so then people might be like okay
ellen if you're encouraging hannah to
not show her kids why do you show your
kids and i think there's a lot of
applications it's there's so many layers
to this and guys this is something both
hannah and i battle with and struggle
with on a weekly basis we've had so many
conversations about it i have actually
for a lot of years
been
deciding like i think it's been like
three years now maybe two years where
i'm like okay i want to transition my
kids off of social media off youtube
especially um how can i do that so at
first i'm like okay because i'm like the
kids are getting older you know and just
just with like you said the experience
of just how nasty the internet can be
which i didn't see in the beginning um
no one knew yeah we didn't understand
privacy back then we just didn't i don't
know if privacy is the word for me for
because i feel like i've always been
very respectful i feel very good with
how i've chosen to show my children on
the internet um i feel very happy with
the amount and the way that i have done
it i've always had these
boundaries of what felt right being
always showing only respectful clips of
my kids sometimes people ask why don't
you show more um like real life quote
unquote moments where your kids are
having tantrums on the internet or like
just other things that would be i don't
know the kids crying or something i'm
like i'm sorry no i'm not gonna do that
just to appease you and make you feel
like i'm a normal family because you
just have to realize i'm a normal family
i'm not going to film my kids when
they're crying or upset like would you
want to be filmed when you're crying or
upset and i always only film when my
kids want to be filmed i actually for
the most part just film my own thing and
then they jump in and i'll sometimes be
like can you go play outside and like no
i really want to make this cookie with
you like all right i guess you're going
to be in it you know it's like like you
said it's like they are completely
immersed in my life and that is one of
the reasons which is my main channel
which is my life right i'm pretty much
just sharing my daily life and
like you said you have one kid i have
four i'm like it is so so difficult to
just like if i had a different job where
i'm just like sit down talking every
video that'll be different but that's
just not the life that i that's not the
job the career that i ended up making on
youtube um be it somewhat unintentional
um so
that being said i'm like thinking what
can i do to help just transition my kids
off the internet through my life
experience of just how quote-unquote and
asking the internet can be and just as
my kids get older it just feels good
like okay yeah my oldest are just
they're getting older like i'm ready to
just transition off of that that's
actually one of the main reasons why i
started the podcast not only because
my main youtube channel i was getting
very um burnt out on sharing the
day-to-day life things um and just
filming in the middle of and just
showing the same thing like how many
different ways can i show my green
smoothie and we go to the beach a couple
times a week and our homeschooling but
also because i was really craving
like having more conversations about
some deeper topics and just to get into
different kinds of topics that my main
channel is just not what it had become
and so i'm like yes this would be
perfect for me to transition this way
and whoever's interested can join along
on my journey and then eventually i can
phase out my main channel so that has
been something that's been on my mind
before i even started the podcast for
like a year that was like my plan in the
works like andre and i are very big
planners we plan ahead and like really
think ahead of things and then the other
aspect of like okay trying to do more
videos without the kids all together and
so i tried doing that for a little bit
um and i i i try my best to be like okay
what's something i can do where they're
less in it and then my kids are like mom
your videos suck now
well they suck but they're like your
videos aren't as good and they're good
anymore i like the videos when we were
in it and i'm like well
okay i mean they don't understand the
bigger picture yeah well i mean my
oldest does like elvis definitely is
aware i think at this point but he
really likes being in the videos and so
i've just kind of found this balance at
this point where i'm just posting less
on youtube and more on the podcast and
i'm eventually transitioning to only the
podcast that is my ultimate plan and it
shouldn't be too far off in the future
and so i'm just posting a lot less on my
channel and i think one of the things
that people like to jump to is that
anyone who shows their kids online is
like the same i know that then everyone
together it's like yeah it's like if you
show your spectrum yeah if you show your
kids online at all then you're just this
all these labels right as opposed to not
seeing the differences in the types of
ways that you show your kids online if
you're showing them when they're really
upset or it's just like constantly in
their faces and it's all about getting
them to do something for clicks like
that's just not that's just not me i
know my heart i know how i've been i
literally have always just been here
being like this is the ellen show
showing my life and then they just kind
of pop in um and there are certain
videos where it's not quite as much like
that um
subtle but for the most part it is and i
feel really good about what i have
shared and there's also so many pros
well let's just talk about how many
lives you've changed i'm sorry but
so many people are going vegan because
of your channel and so many animal lives
are changing and even if they're not
going fully vegan they're just like hey
i want to eat healthier i want to eat
more fruits i'm just showing so people
can see how healthy it is to raise kids
on a plant at least predominant diet you
can see hey these kids look amazing
they're thriving and most people don't
have the opportunity to see vegan kids
yeah but i think aside from this
conversation that shouldn't be a really
big part of the point the bigger picture
like to me the bigger picture is like
what's best for my kids yeah um so to me
that's not really something thank you
for that but for me that's not something
that's like a big part of my like
justification yeah no for me it's like i
do see though that there are so many
pros to the life that we've built and um
and what we do online this family
channel we have because um it literally
is like i think people kind of think
that it's like oh i assume anyone who
has their kids online or on youtube
that's like you just have their camera
in their face all the time but it's
literally once every couple weeks i'm
filming a video and i'm like in the
garden and they're like can i help and
i'm like sure and they come in and um
they they love being in the videos and
what's so incredible is that
is that we have so many memories to look
back on and i honestly feel like my kids
are gonna have such heightened
incredible childhood memories like you
think about your childhood how many
memories you actually remember a lot of
them are only if my parents popped in
the the video camera when they recorded
on that like big cam corner then you
have oh there was my birthday oh i
remember that now yeah but think about
how many memories my kids watch the home
like scout loves watching her home birth
video they love watching their birthday
videos their christmas videos and over
and over again that'll be like can we
watch your youtube mom and they just
love that and the other main pro for me
is that my kids have gotten to grow up
with andrew their dad at home all day
where we are together as a family unit
and you know most families like the dad
most of the time not always but is gone
all day and then you see them at home
for dinner for a couple hours before bed
and what's beautiful about this life
that we have created is that they get to
have their father figure in their life
such an important figure um like all
throughout the day and he has been such
a grounding part like i imagine if they
were like do you want mom to quit and
then dad goes get a job all day like
there's just no way
um
so yeah all that to say is i just these
are not like quote unquote
justifications it's more so the pros and
cons that i balance that i feel this
like
trying to figure out what is the right
thing for our family and overall i do
have that desire to just like gravitate
my kids like towards the podcast oh
sorry gravitate my my um social media
towards the podcast and then um get my
kids off of youtube especially and i've
even like i have so many pictures of my
kids that i just like
i don't post because i'm like i barely
post on instagram anymore and part of
that is because like i don't have very
many pictures of just myself
and i do post um like you know sometimes
pictures of the kids still but i just
feel like it's just not so black and
white and i'm like i'm just i feel like
we just need to all have a little less
judgment of people and realize that
everyone's just doing their best most
people most people are doing their best
and just trying to figure out what is
best for their family well absolutely i
mean there's so many parenting decisions
the moment you get pregnant there's so
many parenting decisions and i
want you know when i went through you
know my first time my midwife asked me
at her six-week visit like what are the
kind of surprises for you and i said you
know the biggest thing i think
i didn't know i would feel is that i
feel literally
just no judgment about how someone else
chooses to parent yeah i might have my
own opinions and there's reasons that i
make my choices but
most of the time
parents are doing what they believe is
best for their kids and they are the
right parents for those those children
so
i just i wish we could all just stop
pointing fingers and just acting as if
someone else cares knows what's best for
my child totally and just saying like
you don't care about your kids or you
don't this this you're doing it wrong
like just have a little less judgment
actually i feel the same way before i
had kids i'd be like i would never do
that i would never do that and then i
had kids and i'm like oh i totally get
why people do these things like just
have a little less judgment for people's
decisions and just show a little more
grace and realize that not everything is
black and white and the whole reason we
brought this up is like a lot of times
people like we said think that we must
have opposing views about this but um we
actually have the same views and we're
just like trying to figure out the best
way i know to move forward and sometimes
guys i want to show cosmo you don't even
know how cute that baby is so cute and i
it's really hard um but it's actually
really nice having like a boundary where
it's like i can't show his face okay
that's the rule i set up for myself
which is limiting for me because i feel
like i would be such an overshare if i
had no limits you know so it's just
really nice to just have sort of a clean
start out clean and that's why i was
really intentional about it when i had
my first kid and i'm already a youtuber
yeah it's different it's like you
already have your kid and then you go
into youtube and you're not really
thinking much because you don't really
have a big audience you haven't been
subject to hate and then you're like
just like look we're just sharing our
lifestyle and it's like oh okay but but
at the same time like i said i feel like
there are so many pros to this career
that i have done and so that's why to me
what feels the best for our family is
that i'm phasing them off and going
towards the pod yes that's my ultimate
goal is to get that is to do that
you know somewhat and i find the
conversation in general interesting even
if you and i didn't have personal
experience with it because the internet
is
our age this is we're in the internet
and
it's
fascinating to know to just dig into
those different
um yeah just the different
uh ways you could handle the internet
yeah totally there's so many different
ways to handle it and there's even like
you know people feel that way even if
you don't even have like an audience or
career about it like you shouldn't show
your kid even if you have like you know
just your close friends on the internet
because you know children cannot consent
type of thing i don't know if i relate
to the children cannot consent they kind
of think kind of thing because there are
so many things that we do as parents
that they that our children do not
consent to so i don't think that's a
valid reason personally but um but i do
think that the well-being of your family
keep doing what you think is the best
for your for your kids
um and most people are really just doing
their best okay so i really hope
this clears it up yeah because i just
get a lot bored of talking about this
yeah no totally i think but i think it's
helpful because people just haven't
heard us talk about it yet yeah and
maybe it's hard for me to talk about
because i
i am tempted to show his face so it's
like stop tempting me you know what i
mean i've set up this boundary i'm gonna
stick to it
so i feel like even just
from this conversation not even just
about this but you know people's
opinions and judgments it's easy to take
things personally um that when people
have their judgments about you but
social media does this thing where
people feel inclined and justified to
just type their thoughts whereas in real
life people don't do that people have
these healthy social filters
where there's certain things that you
know are not helpful or beneficial like
certain things i have to realize that
when people say things not just about
whether i put my kids online or anything
but just anything any kind of criticism
about me or what i look like or how i'm
doing things or what i'm sharing
that the majority of time if someone's
being like you know critical or just
especially if it's like a nasty
something that these people would never
say something
to my face about that and so anyone
online who's not even a social media
person but just not even like a career
person but you're online and you just
experience it or you see it or even just
experiencing judgment in real life like
to to
work on yourself to not take things
personally because what people are doing
is really more about them and not about
you because if somebody is having a
really bad day i've definitely had times
like that or someone said something
really nasty to me online and most of
the time i ignore it or i block and just
move on and someone's just being like
really outright nasty for no reason um
especially if it's not even pertained to
the topic of what i'm sharing um that's
a troll yeah yeah but every once in a
while it's like you know i'm just going
to send a message to them just try to be
kind and if i do do that
most of the time the person is like i'm
so sorry i'm just having a bad day yeah
and just realizing that like
and i've like we've gotten emails before
i've gotten emails before someone
apologizing for something that they said
on my page months ago like i'm so sorry
i was being really nasty i was in this
really bad place and i'm like wow that's
like really big of them and i really
appreciate that um but just overall it's
helpful to just not take things
personally because whatever someone
thinks about you
not even just about internet comments
but just in real life has nothing to do
with you
it's really about them and what they're
going through anytime you find yourself
being quick to judge
like check in with yourself and be like
why am i why do i have these strong
opinions about this other person like
why can i what can i do to work on
myself and that actually comes back to a
video that hannah and i made like four
or five years ago about like are you
women are you doing these six things
stopping now it's probably one of my
favorite videos we made together um but
that's basically one of the main things
we talked about was like are you judging
other people and are you like taking
things personally and stop taking these
personally what do you get any comments
on that i mean yeah i think it's
obviously easier said than done it takes
a lot of inner work um
and
detaching um and some people just are
naturally and sort of discussing the
other day like why are some people just
naturally
so good at
not taking things personally almost to a
fault where you're like they don't
andrew my husband that is him epitome of
someone who does not care what people
think of him and i want to get there
i think i think i'm pretty i think i've
grown a lot and i think that i attribute
that to my
time on the youtube
and um the experience of some really
hard
hard moments where people say things
they make entire videos about me and i
have to realize
wow what a sad person what a sad person
to dedicate your entire
life to making videos
criticizing other people that's really
sad i feel really bad for them that's
really sad it's dark it's very dark
again it's not it's not like uplifting
your own self it's not being your best
self yeah and so when someone and this
is even for anyone listening like in
real life if there's someone in your
life you're like i feel like they don't
like me or you're feeling insecure about
i said this the wrong way maybe they're
thinking this about me like just the
importance of like working on yourself
to just let it go and realize that like
other people's opinions of you is none
of your business i know i i feel like
sometimes eric doesn't understand me how
i truly am like yeah well they can think
that about me he's like what
you only let them think yeah they could
think that about me she can think i'm
being a little forward but i'm just
being honest i really value honesty and
if someone isn't willing to go there
with me i just that's their problem they
can work on it and it might sound a
little crass or it might sound a little
cold
but i don't have time
to to get emotionally involved to like
take care of someone else's feelings you
know like
yes i'm going to be kind and i sound
kind of nasty right now i'm just kidding
i don't know that was some good sarcasm
villain yeah you had to say just kidding
after that yeah i have to say just
kidding right away just kidding
um yeah i don't know it just
yeah i understand i i can come off as
as sort of cold but i'm a nice person
i'm really nice you're so nice i'm not a
rude person but my point is that if
someone
thinks that thinks
something about me that i know not to be
true i don't find it
um that urgent to correct them that's
how andrew is he's very like and a lot
of people who know me and i know that
i've talked about how admirable equality
is i think that andrew is like that like
he's just so good at just being like
well i know who i am inside and like he
cares about um he it's valid to him the
opinions of people who he
feels is respectful someone who he
respects right and um in life but
someone on the internet or someone who
doesn't know him even someone in real
life that he's not close with like it's
okay they think these things about me so
what yeah like i know who i am don't you
think i'm kind of like that though yeah
i do think you're like that thanks yeah
you are good like that i think i'm kind
of good at that oh yeah i mean i feel
like both of us have grown so much from
like what we've experienced on the
internet but it's extended to real life
so i you know i'll have you know sort of
miscommunication with a friend and i'll
do my best to clarify but if they're
still determined to think xyz about me
i'm moving on yeah i'm not like i got
some soup to make
i don't have time i am definitely not
like that i'm very the person that just
like wants to come together no matter
what like wait you're still not like
let's just can we please like i really
just want you to know that i love you
and like can we just work this out like
for me that is
that is a something to a fault for me
that i just always always always want
things to work out and like
sometimes it just depends right on like
the situation what the best thing to do
is with friendships i think a lot of
people struggle with a lot of
friendships a lot of women
and and you kind of think like
in high school it's just the drama and
then when you get older it's all over
but that doesn't always necessarily the
case for some but you know what i think
ellen is like because i sometimes i'll
ha i'll still have some you know
difficult communication with friends and
i really think that when you become a
mom you just need easy friendships you
just don't want to do drama like suggest
all of my all of my heart is going to my
child yes and i can't
i can't i want friends who uplift me and
are honest with me and if they have a
problem with me we can talk about it but
or if they have a problem you can be
there for them yes um yes and but the
hugest factor i think in a quality
friendship is like not taking things
personally and not jumping to
conclusions or making assumptions then
you're just creating a storm for no
reason yeah that's something that like
when you're a teenager a lot of times
it's just something something that your
brain hasn't quite said someone doesn't
text you back right away you see the
three dots and they disappear you assume
you jump to all these conclusions just
let it go who cares but they probably
get interrupted or something well it's
very freeing to live a life where you're
like kind of just very strong on your
own person and it's not like um just
centered around other people's but i
think that's what it is it's a lack of
security in who you are so if you know
who you are and if you're secure this
little rumble over here isn't going to
come crack make everything come crashing
down but is part of it too like
personality differences and like just
the desire to like um
like be a fixer or be someone that's
just like a peacemaker and trying to
bring peace whereas like someone's like
well that's that's how they feel then
just kind of move on like it's part of
that too it's pretty late but maybe the
person who feels you who feels like they
have to fix everything maybe that's part
of who your identity and your security
and who you are like if someone feels
you know something negative about me
then that means something about who i am
or for me it's more like a
misinterpretation or misunderstanding
like a lot of times there's just
miscommunication i know it really is
hard to be misunderstood but that
affects your security and who you are
yeah the the goal is to not let it
affect yourself and who you are for sure
i'm so thankful that i have a husband
like andrew because he's very grounding
um for me too and
yeah he's just very helpful with his
sarcasm and with his just you know
laughing off
you like
but i do what i do sarcastically wait do
i hate it or do i love it i don't know
you guys don't don't question me
[Laughter]
um but how do you feel like motherhood
like you said has changed you other than
just oh my gosh the fact of like you're
like i don't have time for nonsense
what else has changed i feel like you're
you become a new creature you become
someone you become a bit of a cafeteria
because what's that mean
you're just food for like oh a while
you're just food right over my head it's
okay
[Laughter]
and
i think
for me
i know it's a little cliche but i really
feel like i have learned
my
depth and
my strength and how much i can do
because
labor was
labor was labor right that was a really
hard thing that i accomplished i did and
um in the end it was this beautiful
excuse me this like incredible
experience that i can't wait to do again
and i loved having a home birth um
but you know look but it was like an
ultra marathon i can't believe i did
that and and we've talked about two
birth i feel like it's something you do
it's not something that happens to you i
really feel like that distinction is
important to me birth isn't just
happening to me it's like i'm doing this
right now and um that was incredible and
then
you know breastfeeding was a journey
it was so hard four months of many
different lactation consultants and
struggles and so many tears and then
growing from that and releasing that
stress oh it is coming back right now
just like it puts me back i'm telling
you the second time is going to be a
thousand times yes it's so different
i definitely felt that with the first
one it was so hard and confusing i was
like the first time i was i didn't i
didn't have any other young new mom
friends that i was close with and just
like not understanding how to do it like
it was just very confusing it's
definitely something that you have to be
taught how to do it doesn't just super
come naturally most of the time you
would think yeah you think this is what
my boobs are for why can't i just well
that's partly like the journey of like
the the tribal sacred motherhood
womanhood thing of like how the older
generation teaches you
their wisdom and what they've learned
and we've kind of detached from that in
our society
everything's clinical we're separated as
communities and it's just not as
communal as like the way that maybe our
species was intended to the way it used
to be we never saw people breastfeeding
yeah you know i remember as a kid i saw
someone breastfeeding on my couch and i
didn't realize what they were doing they
were how to cover and they were like oh
don't go do it so awkward or boobs out
you know it's just sort of i didn't oh
breastfeeding you know culture is
definitely
different now um but it isn't that way
for everyone in the united states or
maybe across the world still like there
are definitely certain well some people
are going to feel more comfortable with
different things anyways like something
more comfortable to cover up some people
are not and then some people
yeah it just i know i'm not
you're so funny because that's what i'm
talking about no no i'm just saying like
yeah sure you can feel comfortable
covering up everyone do what they want
to do but um my own experience of never
seeing someone breastfeed yes we weren't
breastfed ourselves and it just wasn't
part of our family life your children
are so used to it they're going to have
a different experience when they have
children um yes and then no i was only
bringing that up because i think that
there are there are certain parts of the
country still where there are or maybe
even the world where um it's not
considered normal to breastfeed in
public like not it's not still yeah like
there are certain times that's sad yeah
no definitely i have a story but i'm not
i'm like should i bring it up can we do
it can you
i think it's so beautiful and amazing um
yes but keep going about your motherhood
oh yeah i mean i don't know
i just i feel like i feel like sometimes
i wish i could be more reflective about
this and sometimes i'm just doing it and
there's just so much to do and
it's um
i think some sometimes i'm like i have
no idea what i'm doing i'm just kind of
bouncing my baby like am i doing this
right i have no idea let me text elena's
it's okay you know and i don't know what
i'm doing you know and and sometimes i
think back to pre-baby and i would look
at other people who have one kid two
kids and i just assumed everyone knew
what they were doing
and most people i think are kind of just
winging it yeah they read a couple books
maybe
and they just feel like i'm just gonna
i'm just gonna do what i think is best
well that's why having a community as
best as you can is so helpful because it
helps you get insights and wisdom from
different people
on things that you're like oh i never
even considered that for sure yeah who's
that sandy
yeah we're not done with the podcast yet
close the door close it overnight
i'm getting so hot yeah well um what
okay awesome sandy that's great close
the door
she had a little little cameo yeah
um
where were we from here i forget oh we
were talking about the
um
the journey of like having a community
helping you with and it feels like no
one's really knows what they're doing
and i totally agree yeah it's just it's
just intense motherhood i remember one
of your friends ashley when it came last
year cosmo was six months and she asked
how's motherhood going you know and i
was like it's intense
it's just that's my favorite word for it
it's just a lot
and um especially that first year now
that we're into the second year it just
things are kind of a little smoother and
it feels like we have a bit more of a
rhythm and i feel like i have more
freedom cosmo slept amazing last night
oh my gosh sleep is everything it's like
the sleep you know and uh we were
co-sleeping for a year and now we're
he's learning how to sleep in his crib
and it's truly life-changing to have
a bed to myself
it's this constant evolution journey
like especially as they get to different
ages i love to talk to moms who have
like older older kids with like just
like ideas of what could be ahead oh i
know you know what's funny is um one of
my dear friends isla the one who wrote
who's a novelist um she
uh
became an empty nester the same year
that i became a mom wow so she we were
both sort of going through this like
huge transformation and and she said
that experience of becoming an empty
nester is like
really
really
i don't use the word hard but it's like
it's a bigger deal than she anticipated
i don't feel like our mom and dad acted
like it was a big deal like at all you
know a lot of times you picture the
whole like the parents our parents
aren't very clingy yeah they're not but
we we don't have any parents they're
like bye dude i remember being 16 be
like bye mom and she would never even
ask where i was going i would just be
like fine i'll see you and she would ask
where i was we didn't we didn't have a
curfew which they just trusted us they
just really trusted us and you know if
we came home really late one night
they'd be like it's kind of late it's
like 11 30 and i'm like yeah i'll come
home earlier next time she's like okay
go back to her book
and i honestly i loved that type of
parenting i just really you know felt
trusted compared to a lot of our friends
you know had parents maybe that were
just quick to assume that maybe oh you
must be smoking or you must be doing
this or like i think you're lying to me
and like that just fosters this really
really disconnected relationship but
anyways i feel like we talked about so
many things you know i don't even know
what it was about what is this episode
what is it even about i hope you enjoyed
this conversation um this is kind of how
all our conversations go and when she
comes to visit i love every night after
the kids go to bed we just like sit and
talk but only until 10 because we're
like bedtime
so we get like one hour together and
even before you had cozmo you've always
been so helpful you would come and visit
and just help me with the kids clean all
the dishes make the food and it's so
helpful and i just love you and i love
everything about you and i love our
relationship
and this is how our conversations go
yeah so i hope you liked i hope we can
do it again because it was really fun
and i love digging deep into this kind
of thing and i'm so proud of everything
you're doing and everything you're um
attempting to do and thanks for doing
and i just i think it's incredible and
the amount of attention to detail that
you have is i think
something people don't realize um it's a
lot i'm i'm sometimes it's too much i
think i'm like wait wait no
no the angle's not quite right
you're like ellen hit record
time
anyways thank you so much for being here
we're so excited to have you on the
podcast and i hope you guys really
enjoyed our conversation
you